on va tenter en savoir un petit peu plus
sur ce qui s'est passé hier à toronto
des coups de feu qui ont été tirés dans
le métro sa cause et damman tout un émoi
au centre-ville il ya un homme d'une
vingtaine d'années qui a été blessé par
balle on ne craint pas pour sa vie
alors gabriel sabourin est là pour nous
en parler alors gabriel évidemment les
circonstances donc de cette fusillade
sont encore nébuleuses mais on sait que
des policiers de toronto ont été
impliqués
oui parce que l'unité des enquêtes
spéciales qui est le sien garde des
corps policiers en ontario se penche sur
cette fusillade
ce service enquêtes là chaque fois qu'il
ya des civils sont tués ou encore blessé
grièvement lors d'une intervention
policière
donc les coups de feu ont retenti vers
20 heures hier soir les stations métro
princess et au centre ville de toronto
tout près du centre eaton gérer de
nombreux torontois qui ça sert entre
autres au magasinage du temps des fêtes
il ya certains témoins qui ont affirmé
avoir entendu une dizaine de coups de
feu et qu'elle un climat de panique et
de confusion qui régnait dans métro à ce
moment là donc une section métro a été
paralysée et des toujours d'ailleurs le
pôle enquête qui est en cours
la victime se nomme dans la vingtaine
qui a été atteinte de plusieurs
projectiles d'armes à feu il a été
transporté à l'hôpital entre la vie et
la mort mais il repose maintenant dans
un état stable
on a peu de détails plus détails ont
filtré jusqu'à présent on c'est là que
les positions étaient appelés à
intervenir auprès d'un homme dans un
wagon métro qui est un échange entre la
victime et les policiers avant que la
filière des claques
je remercie beaucoup gabriel